gotta ask you another wild question
what do you think of uh Bob Lazar
who uh claimed that uh he worked at and
saw in Area 51 a propulsional system
fueled by
I'm quoting here maybe from Wikipedia I
don't know where I got this from uh
fueled by an antimatter reactor which
used as fuel the chemical element with
atomic number 115 at the time it wasn't
synthesized it was later in in 2003
synthesized named muscovium
he said that the proportional system
relied on a stable isotope of element
115 which allegedly generates a gravity
wave that allowed the vehicle to fly
into evade visual detection by bending
light around it
no stabilizer dose
of muscovium have yet been synthesized
all have proven extremely radioactive
decaying in a few hundred milliseconds
one do you believe him which I I find
him fascinating because it's uh I find
the human mind even more fascinating
than
um
then then something like an antimatter
drive because I think it's such a giant
mystery that we haven't even begun to
explore deeply anyway
um in that sense whether he's lying or
not are both interesting things to
explore from a psychology perspective
but to
and he's basically saying that I guess
it's an alien
uh extraterrestrial engine thing
um
what do you think I mean I'm happy to
change my opinion based on new evidence
at any point
I have like
the biggest part of me wants to just be
like this is obviously just stupid a
hoax and just total you know quack
and then another part of me still is
like this is exciting and fun to think
that this is all real and then another
part of me goes why
how how good is this guy at lying and
making stuff up because it's oh
really good like good storytelling good
like I don't know what to think honestly
I don't know I'm really very skeptical
about anyone explaining anything like
this like I mean my my radar is like
screaming at me like this is all app
full crap you know
but I'd say like there's still an
apartment just like man that is kind of
cool how did he know that and like you
know what I mean well I think you're
conflicted I think you're actually in
the in the best kind of place because
it's uh
I'm afraid of being the kind of person
that hears something like that and says
it's definitely
um he's definitely full of crap and
basically closed my mind off to all that
stuff I'm afraid of being somebody who
closes my mind off to a thing that's
actually uh a early thread to a
brilliant to it to a future to a
fascinating solution to a mystery so uh
but in this case I mean I have so many
red flags from a psychological
perspective that um
that but again uh outside of this
particular individual I do wonder if
aliens have visited us
I think aliens are everywhere I think
the universe is teeming with alien life
I mean there's
it's very difficult for me to
statistically understand given
how
life finds a way here on Earth just
everywhere the entire history of life on
Earth from the very origin of life it
seems to be damn good at doing its thing
evolving to get better and better and
better at doing its thing now there
could be some special aspects to the
origin of life itself which is
completely not understood so maybe the
true magic is in the origin of life
or it could be that there is some
magical leaps uh to uh eukaryotic cells
for example that the Universe our
galaxies teeming with alien life but
it's all bacteria they're all boring
bacteria or exciting bacteria no offense
to bacteria the but the no intelligence
space-faring civilizations I don't know
but
I just if I were to guess if I had to
bet all my money
there is space-faring civilizations
everywhere in the universe
and the fact that they're not that they
have not been directly definitively
observed
confuses me and I think it's a mystery
and if I were to suggest what solution
to that mystery is is they might look
extremely different from us
and we might be too dumb to detect them
yeah and like and so there I think you
have to be extremely open-minded
at what would we be looking for right
that and that that's a very practical
thing to be open-minded about and
practically speaking if we were to be
able to even detect them from a distance
get a tech techno signature of a distant
planet of a distant star system that has
alien life
honestly the number one thing I kind of
want to know is like
what's your propulsion system
how do we travel faster right like
there's a bunch of details probably but
first let's get together and teach me
how to go fast go fast I like
motorcycles I like rockets exactly what
you got yeah uh yeah like how like I'll
show you mine if you show me yours kind
of thing at the inter Interstellar
Intergalactic level
um yeah anyway I just wonder
maybe it's a cheat code in this video
game would call it life but I wanna I
wanna use the cheat code to figure out
what kind of propulsion systems are
possible and it feels like other alien
civilizations might help us give us
um
give us a guidance on that of course I
think even just
discovering
boy one of the things with a space
program like everything we're doing with
Mars
like the secret thing I'm really excited
about the romantic thing is humans on
Mars but the secret thing is building
giant stations on Mars that allow us to
definitely
hopefully find the traces of life that
either currently doesn't live or has
once lived on Mars because if that's the
case that means for sure life is
everywhere oh 100 and then you're like
and once you know that sorry to keep
interrupting not shutting the hell up is
this supposed to be an interview God
damn it all right uh that uh like that
just the knowledge of that just the
knowledge that a four minute mile can be
run I think we'll open our minds
completely to really really hardcore
push to Interstellar travel or
colonizing Mars becoming multiple entire
species it'd be truly inspiring